خبر عاجل اخر اعلن الاسعاف الاسرائيلي
اصابه اربعه مستوطنين في عمليه دهس جنوب
الخليل بالضفه الغربيه قالت القناه
الثانيه عش الاسرائيليه ان الهجوم وقع
بالقرب من مستوطنه عتنا اييل قرب الخليل
وانه تم تحييد منافذ
الهجوم
الصور التي نشاهد الان هي من موقع تنفيذ
هذه العمليه عمليه الدهس جنوب الخليل
بالضفه الغربيه بالقرب من مستوطنه عتنا
اييل قالت القناه الثانيه عش الاسرائيليه
ان هذا الهجوم وقع بالقرب من هذه
المستوطنه مستوطنه عتنا اييل وانه تم
تحييد منفذ الهجوم نقترب اكثر مما جرى في
الخليل ومن هناك من منطقه واد الشاج نه
جنوب الخليل ينضم الينا مراسلنا منتصر
نصار منتصر ما الذي يجري الان هناك هل علم
المزيد عن هذه العمليه وعن مصير
منافذها نعم يعني نحن نقف في مقابل الموقع
الذي جرى فيه عمليه اطلاق النار مباشره
كما يظهر في هذه الصوره حتى هذه اللحظه
قوات الاحتلال قبل قليل حاولت سياره
الاسعاف الفلسطينيه ان تتقدم باتجاه موقع
اطلاق النار على هذه السياره لكن قوات
الاحتلال ردت باطلاق النار على سياره
الاسعاف يظهر في هذه
الصوره بهذا التجمع لاليات الاحتلال التي
تتواجد في المنطقه منذ حوالي نصف ساعه قبل
قليل قوات الاحتلال هنا في هذا المكان
الذي نقف فيه اطلقت قنابل الغاز وقنابل
الصوت باتجاه المواطنين الذين تجمعوا هنا
في في هذا المكان لمتابعه ما يجري وتنتشر
قوات الاحتلال ب يعني اعداد كبيره في هذه
المنطقه كما ذكرت يعني المعلومات حتى هذه
اللحظه يعني حتى المصادر الطبيه سياره
الاسعاف المتواجده هنا في هذا المكان لا
يوجد لديها اي معلومات حتى هذه اللحظه
متعلقه بمصير من تم اطلاق النار عليه
الاعلام العبري يتحدث عن تحييد منفذ وعن
اصابه اربعه مستوطنين في الموقع الذي نقف
فيه او نقف مقابله مباشره شره تمنع قوات
الاحتلال اي من سيارات الاسعاف او حتى نحن
كصحفي من التقدم قبل قليل قوات الاحتلال
طاردت حتى الطواقم الصحفيه الموجوده في
هذا المكان ومنعتنا من ان نقترب اكثر من
المكان لنلتقط صوره اكثر وضوحا في هذا
الموقع لا تزال قوات الاحتلال تتواجد على
طول الطريق الالتفافي هذا الطريق الذي
يظهر امامنا هو الطريق او خط 60 المؤدي
الى مستوطنه عتنا اييل الواقعه الى الجنوب
من مدينه الخليل هذا الطريق طبعا منذ
السابع من اكتوبر شبه خال من المركبات
الفلسطينيه بسبب قيام قوات الاحتلال بوضع
بوابات حديديه وسواتر ترابيه تمنع
الفلسطينيين من التحرك على هذا الشارع
وعند هذا المدخل بالتحديد مدخل قريه وادي
الشجني هنالك بوابه حديديه ايضا مغلقه
تماما منذ السابع من اكتوبر بمعنى ان
الاجراءات الامنيه الاسرائيليه في هذا
الموقع وعلى طول هذا الطريق هي اجراءات
امنيه مشدده قوات الاحتلال تتواجد بشكل
مستمر وبشكل متواصل بدوريات على طول هذا
الطريق اضافه الى ان هنالك برج عسكري يظهر
الان امامنا في هذه الصوره هذا برج او
نقطه عسكريه مقامه بشكل دائم هنا في هذا
الموقع وهو كما ذكرت مدخل قريه واد الشجني
جنوب الخليل وبالتالي نحن نتحدث كما ذكرت
عن اجراءات امنيه معقده هنا في هذا المكان
وفي غيرها من المناطق والنقاط العسكريه
والابراج العسكريه الواقعه في هذه المنطقه
رغم كل هذه هذه الاجراءات نحن نتحدث حسب
الاعلام العبري حتى هذه اللحظه عن وقوع
عمليه اطلاق نار الاعلام العبري تحدث عن
تحييد المنفذ لكن كما ذكرت الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني نحن كنا نتحدث معه قبل قليل
وكنا نتحدث ايضا مع اسعاف وطواقم اسعاف
بلديه دوره التي حضرت الى المكان هنا ايضا
طاقمي اسعاف حضروا للمكان ل على الاقل
امكانيه التقدم باتجاه السياره التي تم
اطلاق النار عليها وتقديم الاسعاف لمن تم
اطلاق النار عليه قوات الاحتلال منعت
الاسعاف تما من التقدم بل اطلقت النار على
اسعاف الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني وبالتالي
من حيث الموقع الذي نقف فيه الصوره كما
تشاهدون نسق المعلومات على الاقل من مصادر
الاعلام العبري ولا امكانيه على الاقل حتى
اللحظه لمعرفه مصير من تم اطلاق النار
عليه في هذه
السياره تقول اذا وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه ان الهجوم وقع بالقرب من
المستوطنه وانه تم تحييد
منفذ الهجوم بينما يعلن الاسعاف
الاسرائيلي عن اصابه اربعه مستوطنين فيما
يقول انها عمليه تهس جنوب الخليل بالتالي
كل هذه التفاصيل من مصادر اسرائيليه فقط
حتى الان ولا معلومات اخرى من مصادر
مختلفه منتصر بالتالي يصعب حتى الان
الحديث عن ما جرى عن طبيعه هذه العمليه
ولماذا اطلق جنود الاحتلال
الناره هناك ما ادى الى وقوع هذه الاصابات
بالاضافه ايضا الى منع وصول سيارات
الاسعاف الى هذا الموقع ولا معلومات
عن المنفذ الذي تتحدث عنه وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه ما الذي تمكنت من الحصول عليه
من معلومات اخرى
منتصر بخصوص ما جرى يعني هناك استنفار
امني الان اجراءات امنيه مشدده قبل وقوع
هذه العمليه هل بدا الحديث عن ربما قراءات
لما يمكن انه جرى هنا في هذا
الموقع نعم يعني نحن كنا تحدثنا قبل قليل
ايضا لسكان هذه المنطقه هم تحدثوا عن سماع
اصوات اطلاق نار في المنطقه قبل هذا
الاستنفار الذي نشاهده الان في هذه الصوره
من قبل قوات الاحتلال يظهر ايضا في هذه
الصوره اسعاف اسرائيلي
ايضا متوقف على مقربه من موقع اطلاق النار
الذي جرى
وبالتالي يعني شهود العيان والاهالي هنا
يتحدثوا عن سماع اصوات اطلاق نار لكن مصير
من من من من من هو بداخل هذه السياره وغير
معروف حتى هذه اللحظه لسببين السبب الاول
كما ذكرنا قوات الاحتلال تمنع الاسعاف
ومنعتنا ايضا نحن كتوام صحفيه من الاقتراب
من المكان السبب الثاني هنالك ايضا
استنفار امني كبير ليس فقط في هذه الصوره
التي تظهر امامنا عند عند موقع اطلاق
النار بل في محيط المكان بشكل كامل حتى
الموقع الذي نقف فيه عندما بدانا بهذه
الرساله المباشره مريم قوات الاحتلال
تقدمت باتجاهنا وحاولت عرقله عملنا ايضا
لكن بالكاد استطعنا على الاقل ان ان ننقل
هذه الصوره بسبب الاستنفار الكبير في هذه
المنطقه كان هناك تجمع لعشرات المواطنين
الذين يقفون في مقابل هذا الموقع تماما
قوات الاحتلال قامت باطلاق قنابل الغاز
والرصاص باتجاههم لتفريقهم وبالتالي
بالفعل نحن نتحدث عن استنفار امني كبير في
المنطقه ونتحدث عن منع قوات الاحتلال
لتقدم الاسعاف الفلسطيني واطلاق النار
عليه لكن يظهر اسعاف اسرائيلي في هذه
الصوره ولا زلنا بالتاكيد نتابع الصوره
للمتابعه بالتاكيد منتصر النصار لما يجري
في هذا الموقع في منطقه وادي الشاج نه
جنوب الخليل شكرا جزيلا لك حت